[Music]
As you walk into the Knight Management Center and you look
to the left, you will notice the cornerstone of the center
with an inscription that reads "Dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet and the people who are going to dream
them up". And I love that inscription because to me it so
completely captures the essence of what the GSB is about
which after all is innovation and it speaks to our twofold
mission. On the one hand it is the creation of the ideas by
the faculty in a great research university which will inform
the practice of management. On the other hand that portal is
a portal to generations of students who will enter the
complex and begin a process of personal transformation, a
process that will enable them to dream up those things that
haven't happened yet, and through that, to change lives,
change organizations and change the world.
In the curriculum we start with other core perspectives, we
deal with issues like ethics, strategic leadership and the
global context of management. These are the core concepts
that a leader who is looking at how to take their
organization forward has to be familiar with. We also then
do a deep dive into every core foundation. This is the
nitty-gritty of the basic management skills and knowledge
that any leader of the management organization has to
master. We are talking about finance, operations, marketing
and so on. But to really change the world, you have to know
how to lead and we think that that involves three essential
capabilities. Firstly, you need to be able to understand
what the problem is. So that's where critical analytical
thinking comes in. Then you need to think about what the
solution is. Well that's where innovation comes in. Finally,
you have to be able to take that and implement it, and that'
s where personal leadership comes into effect. Our approach
to critical analytical thinking is pretty unique. We start
with a very intimate seminar in the full quarter. In that
seminar, we look at some pretty interesting issues for
example, what should Google do in China and we look at the
HP's decision around Mark Hurd's resignation. But what we
are really doing beyond our focus on the issues is teaching
our students about argumentation.
Personal leadership starts with self-awareness and then it
is about how you interact with others. There are couples of
things that are distinctive and unique about our approach.
One builds on the long legacy of the GSB which is of course
interpersonal dynamics known to many as touchy feeling. The
other is coaching, helping them to learn through skills
based exercises how to be effective leaders. The third
capability is innovative thinking. Here, we are moving
aggressively to try to incorporate some of the learnings we
have gotten from working with the design school around
innovation. An example of the kind of collaborative work
that we have done there is Jim Patell's course on
Entrepreneurial Design for Extreme Affordability. We are
tremendously excited that this personal transformation is
going to have a new home in the Knight Management Center
which opens in this spring. The Knight Management Center has
8 buildings arranged around three plots with a wide variety
of space that's quite different from what we have now. More
flat classrooms, more breakout rooms and we are going to
have a co-lab which is a garage like space where the
students are going to be able to roll up their sleeves and
do innovative new projects in an actual hands-on way. We
envision a space that is very collaborative, a space where
students get together around a table to dream up the next
business plan the way Phil Knight did while he was at the
business school. It is really a home for innovation. As the
Knight Management Center approaches completion, I really
want to thank you for all of your contributions, great and
small which have made this possible and I look forward to
your continued participation in the life of the school
whether it's as the mentor, as a volunteer, coming back for
your reunion or as a donor. Thank you so much for being part
of the life of the school and for everything that you do for
us. If you really want to see the impact on our students,
please click on the link on the page, we have got recent
quotes from our students who describe their own personal
transformation.